[Musique]
considéré comme l'un des pionniers du
reggae en france tonton david avait
donné son dernier concert à la réunion
en 2016
dans ces images transmises par un fan on
le voit lors de l'inauguration de la
cité des arts on peut pas dire vraiment
que j'ai baigné dans le reggae par
exemple dans ma jeunesse ma jeunesse
j'ai baigné de lorsqu'une donc tout ce
que j'ai pu écouter dans sur la fm mais
ça a été la musique qui m'a donné envie
un jour de d'écrire des textes et
et composer coup droit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puisque j'aime avant tout c'est faire
des chansons assez forte alors
qu'importe le site de la musique mais
forcément dans le style d'interprétation
ça sera forcément reggae populaire pour
ses paroles son style direct et bon
enfant
tonton david savez ne pas se prendre au
sérieux un regard façon au nom de la loi
avec tous écrits façon sergio leone sa
fameuse série b c'est patrice porno
sérieux c'était marrant j'aimais bien
dans la chanson sûr et certain en 1994
il dénonce l'abandon des outre-mer par
le pouvoir central
je suis aperçu qu'en fait il va de son
petit laïus en fait on se rend compte
qu'on la remarque t il
alors je me suis dit ben moi je vais
aller du miel pour dire que avoir vaincu
le raggamuffin c'est pas de la musique
c'est justement c'est surtout de se
débrouiller
c'est un rappel c'est d'être pas pour le
vol
mais
pas pour la police squad sur vous et que
je sais pas là pour pleurer mais ma
femme c'est que je suis comme un
prisonnier
elle me fait la misère je ne sais
comment m'en sortir j'ai vraiment envie
de bouger tellement elle me fait
souffrir
[Musique]